hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to nighttime visitor now
this game is an indie horror game made
for a game jam a while back and let me
set the scene for you you're working
late in an office late at night when you
suddenly get a visitor of unknown
origins whose only mission is to murder
you dead through strangulation of the
bus that's all I know about the game
because I literally know nothing else
about the game except it kind of takes
place in the office now the reason I saw
this while going into you and I was
gonna play it but I know really is that
really the basic premise of this game
I'm sorry to laugh at it but he's coming
to get me he's gonna getcha
he's like Chucky he's gonna stab me in
the ankles until I'm dead he can only
reach as high as my butt so he's the
perfect crazed bud stabber alright so
anyway that threw me for a loop there
actually there oh yeah I was saying the
reason I didn't play it before is
because when I first took a look at it
it seemed very simplistic so I didn't I
didn't play it right away but a lot of
you guys have been recommending it to me
and also I realized that I was biased
because sorry hello mail room hello may
I come in
I'm gay hello hi could you not do that
did you not do that please do not
breathe in my ear please hello mail room
I've got a problem
that one's oh there we go I guess I
guess we're done here okay goodbye Jesus
what am i hello
okay so I don't exactly know what I'm
supposed to be doing I mean in most of
these indie or games the only objective
is to not die which is as good an
objective as anyone playing in these
games
Davis hello why am i knocking on doors
house
I need a doctor so badly my jokes are
terrible done everyone's done with this
video
okay anyway oh thank you I was hoping it
was gonna be the breathing I was really
hoping okay all right bye then okay
received call yeah I know about that oh
man
so what am I supposed to be doing here
what's that hello hello no okay all
right then ooh that's high course what
are you know go Jamie is the size of
jerky Wow and was the old a gazelle
phone oh oh oh I'm sorry whoa oh my god
okay man this game is full of surprises
so is this why that guy he looked like
he was drawn with crayon oh what is this
place what is this oh man horrifying oh
man oh I thought that was a wall okay
nevermind then it's not a wall not a
wall at all I'm guessing those are
skyscrapers and what is happening okay
yeah this is why I don't let my bias
stop me from playing games or at least I
shouldn't because they can come up with
really interesting things like this and
I don't know what this is but I like it
hello am i becoming the killer is it
like an endless loop of becoming the
killer okay is that the end oh oh no I'm
back oh god no it's like a stanley
parable thing yeah heard you're working
late tonight I was gonna say that
yeah okay thanks Alex you're a doll I
love you oh no signal okay so I can't
call him you move slow with your phone
out oh well have I been doing that whole
time I have no idea
so obviously I'm supposed to avoid him
but what am I supposed to do just get
out why won't anyone help me hello
I need help driving down there probably
not no one wants to help me I'm scared
and alone I'm scared and alone I mean I
have you guys with me and that's a great
comfort to me and I I appreciate you
guys being here and I love you very
dearly but you're not gonna help me from
dying a horrible death
right do I need to answer this hi
it's the same thing it's the same thing
why do I need to talk to you
oh god damn it who's that uh I don't
know why this game's give me the
heebie-jeebies this is I know the
monsters tiny oh god oh god what is this
what is this what where am i oh god what
was that was that something important I
don't know what that was who I don't
know what that was
oh well that's out ominous at all
hmm what's happening oh I thought it's
getting dark I thought I thought my fin
was going black I thought it was passing
out yeah alex is your hands a be end of
a sonnet hmm oh god damn it
what's on exit sign what am i doing oh
hello
hi it it is the outside wait what does
that sign say what exit exit that way I
just came from that way think that which
way I feel like I'm just wandering in
goddamn circles over and over again
which which way that way Oh goddammit I
did go in a big goddamn circle I did
[ __ ] I knew I did I knew I did
where's this lead whoa what is that whoa
what is this [ __ ] God
god dammit
where was I going the signs were all
illogical the side route is going in
goddamn circles there's no exit
there's no exit at all it was all a
bunch of lies it was a bunch of lies it
was just nothing but lies endless
endless lies I I swear
where else could I have gone I was it
was like those like straight paths for a
long time
and then it was his looping circles and
that did I like I had a choice to go
around that way and it was just one big
looping circle like what else could you
have done there was nothing to do I
don't know I don't know what else I
could have done I need to look up to see
even if this is beatable I don't hang on
I'll be right back oh my god oh my
[ __ ] god I was right there I was
right there
I was right there I was at the end I oh
my god shut the [ __ ] up Alex I was
literally literally I was inches from
the exit I was right there I went all
that way and that took a while cuz we
don't exactly go fast here that took a
long time I was right there and
apparently I just got lucky that I
didn't get killed so that like that
beginner's luck that one shining brief
moment I could have won and yet I didn't
because I'm an ass I mean it's not my
fault I didn't know but oh I you you do
not know if I beat this and I hope I do
but you never know what this thing if I
beat this you guys will see exactly how
close I was hello are you just you're
just breathing okay so that's nothing
but breathing there's nothing to those
calls but breathing which is lovely
lovely breathing by the way but not what
I'm looking for
oh jeez ins was it this long
I don't know if those sounds actually
mean anything or if my death is actually
impending left ear oh I think I might
have I don't think I did wait no hang on
I didn't uh said it idiot
I don't remember the way that I went was
that God something just hold down here
this looks familiar
okay so I think I went down here ooh
okay so uh yeah the ominous looking
hallway that's right I remember this so
this is the right way okay so you see
these these windows here these windows
these windows yeah you remember them you
remember the windows I might I might
actually do this okay so this is good
okay so this is good I might actually do
this we shall see we shall see okay it
was right here
I got misled by that sign back there
there's another sign over here and it's
right there I was right there on my
first like real try my first ride well
obviously had no idea yeah I was right
there I was right there oh man I
congratulate you for escaping that place
thank you for playing this silly thing
happy Halloween
so that was nighttime visitor I somehow
navigated the entire game through sheer
blind luck and then I was misled at the
end by bullshitter II I shouldn't have
trusted the sign well I've been trusting
the signs before that like goddamn it
either way so I'm pissed about that but
I still did it so we're done so thank
you everybody so much for watching let
me know what you thought of this game it
was really interesting because the creep
factor was really there like lurking
through those hallways like cuz the
first time I went through I died like
right away like right in that opening
hallway like I died very very quickly
but it was just weird because I thought
it was gonna be much more like deadly
than that and it was just like this
impending sense of dread going down to
another hallway and being like oh [ __ ]
there's more so that was pretty well
made about it I did like that a lot but
then again the graphics are pretty
simplistic but you shouldn't criticize
too much so thank you everybody so much
for watching and as always in the next
video bye bye what awaits me in the
darkness everybody okay look funny
yeah oh God oh hi sorry didn't quite
notice what you weren't person but uh
how's it going